Each one of us, whether or not we like
to admit it is an emotional being.
You're going to get the opportunity to
hear experts from around the world talk
about what they know best human emotion.
You'll not only get to
learn about what emotion is,
what are the mysteries behind it, you
know, where do our emotions come from?
Or how can we harness them to
lead healthier and happier lives?
But you'll actually get to see the people
behind the science and technology of
human emotion.
So you may be sitting there wondering,
why should I care about emotion? You know,
how does it connect to me?
This series is going to answer that very
question because you're going to see
people who come from these very different
backgrounds tell you why you act the
way you do.
Why perhaps sometimes we can't control
our tiers or we have uncontrollable
laughter. Why are we built
this way in the first place?